all right now for part b what i'm going
to do is i'm going to start you off
but i'm going to um pause in the middle
of it because there's plenty of
opportunity for you to use the knowledge
that you already know
um to work through this and see if you
can come up with an answer yourself
now we have all this other information
to deal with and it says
that golfer strikes a ball we've got
this initial speed of 60 meters per
second so
fire that away i know the flight time
4.53 seconds
and i know how far it ends up 155 meters
away so i'm at some point gonna need to
substitute these in
probably i mean you've seen this enough
times by now probably to find out
and evaluate constants of integration
because we're going to integrate as we
go through here from acceleration from
velocity and to determine what the
constants are at each step i will need
these constants to help me
and they need this data to help me from
there i need to calculate an angle of
projection and let's just for the sake
of consistency
let's all call that theta
how do i do this where do i begin well i
want you to have a look at the
information that's provided right
um did you notice in part a gave us this
clue it said hey
gravity is 9.8 you're going to need that
right and that's sort of the nudge to
say hey it's terminal velocity
you're considering this vertically right
in part b
the question says it lands 155 meters
away so i want you to think about this
for a moment right
if you were to think about the situation
if we were to come up with the um
cartesian equation which
mercifully we don't have to and then
graph it right you saw this on tuesday
you'd get this thing which looks like a
um a parabola someone sort of rammed
uh off from the side because it's sort
of slowing down horizontally maybe not
that obvious but i did this just to
make it a little obvious and extreme and
then it lands somewhere right
now when the question says it lands 155
meters away
where is that on this diagram and the
answer is it's here
this landing position right so this 155
meters away
in other words it's actually a
horizontal it's an x piece of
information
it's not a y piece of information in
fact we hardly have to answer anything
about why um we've already found out
from part a what the term velocity is
but you don't have to find out like how
high does it go
at what time does it reach its maximum
height those kinds of things those are
vertical displacement questions we've
been given horizontal displacement
information
so following one from part a which dealt
with y dot we're now going to transition
to think about
x dot and x double dot so
let's think about this uh this
information up here right we've got this
drag force that is proportional to the
square of the velocity and i highlighted
right at the start
that there's no mention of mass right so
therefore
um when i think about the force acting
horizontally
force equals mass times acceleration so
horizontally i can say
that force which by definition
is mass times acceleration
what is it equal to well the question
said the drag force is proportional
to the square of the velocity it's
slowing me down
so it's acting the opposite direction
it's proportional and i've worked out
that drag coefficient and the drag
coefficient horizontally
should be the same as the drag
coefficient vertically
by the way i might just pause for a
moment and ask you in the chat how i
know that
how did i know that the drag coefficient
horizontally should be the same as the
drag coefficient
vertically because in reality it isn't
um but well sorry i should say in
reality in some situations it isn't
but for this question we can actually
know so i it's just
i wasn't planning to do this but it's
such an interesting um thing to say and
something i don't want to
skirt past can you go ahead and post in
the chat if you have no idea just say i
have no idea because that will give me
an indication i need that
or does anyone have a thought as to why
in this particular situation
we ought to expect the same drag
coefficient horizontally
as vertically any takers okay great
suggestion from varenn which is firstly
yes i am absolutely traveling through
the same fluid horizontally
as vertically doesn't change uh
bahn suggested like there's no wind i'm
going to say
yeah i suppose you could you could say
there's no wind however that would just
add another force
i guess and if it was wind i mean i
guess depending on hopefully we
won't have too much changing wind that
would just be another thing to include
in my equation
right small difference in altitude so
there's minimal difference in air
density oh i really like that that was
not where my brain was going
but i'll take that because uh you know
assuming we have a golfer who can't hit
into the stratosphere and so it's like
well up there i have less air resistance
to worry about
and now sean said aha here we go i was i
was wondering if anyone would get there
it's a ball so the air resistance will
be the same for vertical and horizontal
i'll push on that just a little more
what kind of ball is it it is a it's a
spherical ball maybe if you haven't
played golf before i haven't seen a golf
ball before
maybe that's a bit unfair to expect but
not all balls are spherical
because it's a spherical object it's
perfectly
it's you know the most symmetrical thing
you can have in three dimensions right
so no matter which perspective
which angle you look at it um horizontal
vertical
or some other oblique thing even if
you're not orthogonal you'll get the
same cross-section
right we often try and eliminate this by
saying
it's not a golf ball or an object it's a
particle so that whichever angle you
look at it
it's the same profile but that's what's
going on here and i guess i'm trying to
contrast things like a parachute
which experiences vertical drag that
is enough to slow you down but is trying
not to experience horizontal drag
because that will take you off to
somewhere else
or things like a plane which are trying
to do the reverse right a plane
is trying to give you lots of um
vertical uh
drag so you have the lift underneath the
wings um and not much horizontal drag so
you can
go fast and as mrs leaders point out afl
football or um
yeah just rugby league football anything
like that okay sorry that was um
an unplanned segway um an unplanned
aside
we haven't even finished our horizontal
uh force equation here so i've got um
f over here as it were horizontally mass
times acceleration
i'm acting against it i've got the same
drag coefficient that's what we paused
on
and then it's proportional to the square
of the velocity
so the velocity is x dot and then i
square it so this should look familiar
from the equation that we wrote up here
but here i was saying you know
in this balancing situation with
terminal velocity here i'm saying it's
much more
generally okay and you'll notice there
is no mention of mass
on the right hand side and that's
important because apparently this drag
force is not proportional
doesn't care about how heavy the golf
ball is which makes sense okay now
i need to get to um some set of
equations that can help me to use the
information in the question
and i know things about velocity um and
i know things about displacement so i'm
going to need to integrate my way up
there okay
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
start you off i'm going to highlight the
difference between this and the question
we did on tuesday and then i'm going to
give you a
decent chunk of time to work on this on
your own and then you can check back in
with me in the chat if you think you've
got an answer okay
so to integrate up right i've got this x
double dot over here
and to integrate that i'm going to make
things a bit tidier
and get that mass constant over there on
the right hand side and keep in mind
i do know what k is um and i do know
what m is but i'm not writing it just
yet because it's just going to make my
working messier i'm happy to just leave
it as
uh pronumerals right because you can see
up here my numbers are gross and messy
right
okay so from this i as i've done many
times before need to
pick a form for acceleration that makes
it easiest for me
to uh use the information that i've been
given and get towards the
information um or the rather the
destination the question i've been asked
right
so i won't label this point is it can be
v dv on dx is it going to be half v
squared
none of those i want to get towards time
right because i've been told
that it's airborne for 4.53 seconds so
therefore the particular
form for acceleration i'm going to use
um is dv on dt
but it's not v in this case it's x dot
that's the particular velocity i'm
interested in so
uh dx dot on dt and um nothing's really
changing over here
on the right hand side okay now
at this point here you're like oh i know
what to do with this i need to sort of
separate
out my variables a little bit like we
did in extension one and get ready
to integrate so in order to do that
think carefully at what you've got here
and as i promised contrast is to what we
had on tuesday
do you remember sorry to scroll very
quickly away um this is what we kind of
created
um on tuesday's lesson where we were
looking at projectile motion with
resistance
and we looked at and said whoa hold on a
second that looks a whole lot like
exponential decay and so we just
launched straight into
an a e to the negative kt situation
right
um i know a few of you had a look at the
video that explained
a bit more of the first principles like
integrating and why you end up with the
exponential function and so on
um but not all of you so if that's still
like rattling around the back of your
brain please go and have a look at it
it's on the canvas page
but here's the contrast right this is
not the situation we're looking at
we're looking at a quadratic drag um
model
this morning and so you don't look at
this and say oh it's
exponential decay this is not
exponential decay this is going to be
something different when we integrate so
i'm going to do my separation of
variables and see what i end up with
when i put over all of the i've got
these this sort of dx dot term over here
so i'm going to divide through by
x dot squared so that will give me
x dot to the power of negative 2. do you
agree with that just
index laws there i'll leave the dx dot
there on that side and i'm going to kick
the dt over to the other side so that
gives me
minus k over m dt
and at this point here i'm sort of ready
to go so i can integrate from here so
i'm going to be so lazy
on the next line all i need to do is add
integral signs so i'm going to do them
here but i'll just highlight them
in a different color for you okay now
even though it looks weird
see through the mess of note notation x
dot and all that kind of thing
this is uh you could call it v if you
like
and integrate with respect to v this is
just polynomial like this is just a
power rule right
all i need to do is take that power
increase it
by one and then divide by the new power
right and
at the moment my power is negative two
so it's going to increase
by one to negative one and then i'm just
going to divide through by the new power
dividing through by negative one is the
same as multiplying by negative one so
i've just integrated left hand side no
exponential in sight that's because this
is quadratic drag not
linear drag there's the left hand side
and then on the right hand side we just
get this
linear function in time and now i've got
a constant to deal with
okay now here's my last nudge and then
you guys
are going to go for it right as promised
we're going to need to find out
um oops sorry that was really sneaky
that should be x dot not
x we're not a displacement yet i'm going
to need to use some initial conditions
here
right i'm going to need to find out okay
at time
0 what can i say to evaluate this
constant
now when time is 0 we're going to start
at the origin in terms of displacement
so i can say when times 0
x is 0. that's great but i can't use
that yet because i don't have a
displacement equation i've got a
velocity
equation so you're gonna need to work
out what the horizontal velocity is
when you go back to the question they
they rudely don't tell you what the
horizontal velocity is
they just tell you the initial speed and
as we know speed is a scalar
doesn't care about what direction you're
going in so it's even off at an angle
and that angle is what we're trying to
find
so what you're going to do is go all the
way back to thinking about
how do we separate these things i'm
gonna have to resolve forces as i
mentioned
at the beginning you can do this a lot
of ways but
for me i go back to this and i know all
your teachers will do it slightly
differently but
i always like to go back to sort of this
rectangle here in which
my projection vector sits and i know
it's going to have
a speed of 60 so that's the magnitude of
the projection vector
i think we decided to call the angle of
projection theta
and we don't know what that is but from
there i can work out
what x dot and y dot are equal to
because
i just have this sitting in a right
angled triangle can you go ahead
and i actually don't need to worry about
the vertical
velocity the initial vertical velocity
but can you post in the chat what our
initial horizontal velocity will be just
on the basis of this
right angled trig go ahead and tell me
what you think it is when t equals
zero aha well done friends even been
a high uh overachiever and gone to find
the greek letters
absolute thumbs up well done um yes it's
gonna be 60 cos theta because in this
triangle here
and also credit to liam thank you cos
theta will be x dot
on 60 so therefore i just have to
multiply through so that's
60 cos theta here obviously if we needed
it
y dot would be 60 sine theta but that's
just irrelevant for us
so i've got an initial condition and i
can use that to substitute in
to find out what the constant is so as
promised
you've still got a long way to go but
i'm going to pause i think you have
having integrated this quadratic drag
model
and found out it's not an exponential
it's something else
um we've got this uh indefinite integral
and you have the information you need to
work out what that constant will be
eventually you're gonna have to do this
again and get to a displacement equation
work out the constant you get there
so i guess i really should say this is
constant one and let's just
describe that like so so i'm going to
pause remember i'm going to give you a
good 10 minutes
because there's a lot of numbers that
are going to be flying around here and
i know when i was giving this question a
go i fell into a couple of little
crevices and nooks and crannies just
with the arithmetic so be careful
um have a go if you are struggling along
um just
pop us a message either to everyone or
in the direct messages
but if you have an answer and let us
know it's 805 so i'm going to give you
till
um yeah i'm going to give you until
quarter past
um which is a big amount of time but
there's a lot of twists and turns here
and maybe you're still catching up
you're working
if you arrive and answer sooner just let
me know and that will give me an
indication that we can move
before quarter past but i'm going to go
on mute
and uh you guys can have a go at the
question in peace